last night during a live stream that we
were doing covering the latest uh news
um jason whitlock appeared on the tucker
carlson show jason whitlock is uh his
background is as a sports journalist but
he's become kind of like a christian
right wing uh nut commenting on politics
and his entire appearance on the tucker
carlson show lasted under three minutes
and basically tucker carlson just teed
up jason whitlock
to
go on a very strange anti-transgender
word salad which tucker carlson seemed
to absolutely love this is quite
literally insanity this it sounds like a
crazy person talking listen to this
beware all euphemisms
they're always a cover for lying and
misdeeds gender affirming care that's a
phrase you're seeing everywhere
including conservative media to their
great shame what is gender affirming
care well it's castrating children it's
exactly what it is and it's become
finally or it's becoming illegal in some
states but of course activists are
trying to circumvent the law the law the
rule of law
so the person behind the site or the
twitter feed libs of tick tock just
unearthed evidence of a drug smuggling
operation aimed at young children
lipstick tick tock found this online
post from someone called eli ehrlich he
says he's a phd student at uc santa cruz
quote if anyone needs hormones you can't
get access message me ehrlich wrote i
have a network with years of extra doses
now understand
the right is getting a lot of mileage
from anti-trans rhetoric if you looked
at see if you watched the clips from
cpac a couple of weeks ago in texas
the biggest applause lines and standing
ovations were for overtly homophobic and
transphobic assertions and that's why
they're all picking up on it now relic
said he wants to send these drugs to
quote trans youth
now that's a crime of course but
needless to say the doj has refused to
investigate jason whitlock is the host
of fearless he joins us tonight to
assess what's going on so the doj
there is an effort to give drugs
illegally to kids that will castrate
them but the department of justice is
not interested
no they're not interested because
anything that has to do with gender
identity anything that has to do with
diversity equity and inclusion
they're all for and and tucker i'm gonna
go really big picture here but but and
i've said this before but all of this to
me is just satanic that's right guys
this is satanism it's it's absolutely
sad i'm sorry it's not satanism
it's the work of the devil is what jason
whitlock believed what a great analysis
on a major cable network targeting
of young people and children that are
very
impressionable at a very early age and
now we got someone trying to sell them
uh puberty blockers or hormones that
will change their identity
and and it all goes back to this country
was founded by people
who believed our rights came from god if
they believed that they also believed
that that belief should have nothing to
do with civil government which is a
little detail jason whitlock leaves out
and when i look at the left they want to
disrupt that founding principle that
this is a country founded on biblical
principles what he means is the left
wants separation of church and state as
the founders wanted as well
they want to disrupt all of that and
what we're going through right now
tucker is a process called sifting and
it's in the bible one of the last things
jesus said to his disciples luke this is
supposed to be an analysis about policy
understand the insanity
and tucker looks confused but tucker
likes this this is supposed to be an
analysis about policy and he's talking
about sifting in the bible chapter 22
verse 31 he tells peter he calls him
simon says the devil wants to sift you
the sifting process is separating us
it's all these different identities that
they've invented in our lifetime
cisgender
non-binary
you're a republican you're black you're
white you're gay you're lesbian you're
this you're that we're all being
separated and our founders saw us as all
coming from one creator it's really
funny
when the people espousing the divisive
rhetoric
bemoan that the country is divided it's
a real irony
and even for non-believers that founding
work for all of us but as we're being
separated like wheat
we're that's why there's so much
divisiveness in this country
jason like the only person who would say
that on tv and we're grateful that you
did good wow
what what courage it took for jason
whitlock to show up on tucker's show and
give us this bizarre anti-trans
religious nuttery word salad but imagine
watching this episode last night and
thinking wow
jason whitlock really nailed it
sadly there are millions of people who
will watch that segment and say this guy
really speaks the truth and that's a
very very scary thing